mais dis donc ce serait pas un brésilien
mais c'est tout c'est julien lausanne
c'est mon pote du brésil il est venu
spécialement pour le meet up
d'aujourd'hui hockey n'est pas venue du
brésil exprès pour le meet up mais le
fait est qu'il a réglés hier qu'il avait
réservé sa place au décalage horaire du
coude après ça qu'elle a sur place eut
pris ma place il était dans les cinq six
heures du matin quelque chose
regardez-moi 6h services et pavot
l'amitié au 1er janvier j'avais lancé le
mental blog en dix ans le faire une
vidéo par jour au savon en ville et on
était à nos abonnés c'était ma mère est
là on est quand aujourd'hui on est le 12
octobre et on né le 12 octobre et on a
cent trente sept mille abonnés merci sa
cellule grâce à vous et comme prévu je
vais faire mon meetup youtube serait
évidemment pour ceux qui ne sont pas là
qui ne sont pas google aujourd'hui je
vous emmène avec moi je regarde c'est
pas trop joli ça ça c'est marine besson
que tout le monde croit que mon meetup
je le fais à paris en fait on est au
dessus de paris
on est justice il a des corps hyper high
tech avec un téléphone à touches d'un
trois bouteilles pour 85 de fleurs gérer
les amis ça c'est la vaysse combat de
voler avant de partir fait une trace
vidéo
une dernière fois mais méchant et
découvert il ya pas longtemps mais ce
terme à la découverte de l'année et a
aussi comme ça a été vraiment meilleur
effet une vidéo par jour ' tu es
vraiment courage est donc blanchi lance
un petit bonne continuation part et que
c'est maintenant ou jamais pour te dire
quelque chose alors quelque chose comme
en vidéo par jour pendant l'année lundi
bissextile en plus publiquement les
simpson
quand tu regardes cette première vidéo
alors fait le film toi p un plateau pour
madmoizelle.com le site sévère commotion
qu'organise tidende artistes
yann meuf qui s'appelle le la d'une
maison qu'on se rend compte on se marre
en loge plus long et quand on est jeune
mais qui fait partie ainsi qu'au bar
garden et cannes chaîne selon une
rencontre lavage sans trop bien ces
coupes et on part en part et j'ai quoi
je bois en même temps je fais des vidéos
sur 10 mois ci prend bien on commence à
discuter de créateurs à créateur c'est
ouf c'est trop bien et touche même
espèce d'anguille je te jure que c'est
vrai la divine et donc trois cent mille
abonnés
et pareil c'est un certain jo tu verras
mais j'aimerais trop qu'on fasse il
vivait ressemble t d'accord et vous tu
sais je regarde mon planning des
légendes à aller vers ça va oui enfin un
truc vraiment cartonné en tout cas de
mon point de vue fiscal a fait doubler
ma chaîne j'étais à 17 mouche passer à
34 déjà j'avais toujours en stock mais
cette vidéo sur youtube
j'avais tourné six mois de février au
cas où un joueur soit malade mais si je
suis malade je fais quoi en fait ce
public quoi moi dans mon lit et a
présidé cette vidéo comme ça dans la vie
de ce cube en disant si j'aime galère je
sors ça et j'ai pas eu de galère et à
partir de fin juillet jusqu'au 31 août
je vous dis ok je vais sortir les cette
vidéo tropics cube pour aller au
festival d'avignon prend le temps
d'aller tout et après je vais prendre un
mois où je vais calmer mes vacances et
calais tout un travail pour la suite de
l'année et je voulais tourner ici en une
journée 32 vidéo
donc mon studio qu'elle abat sur j'aime
bien c'est les énigmes l'été quoi je me
rends pas non seulement pas mais c'est
d'abord des témoins pour son mariage est
ce qui se rapproche le plus d'un
meilleur ami j'ai fait bataille vous
savez que c'est ça aussi qui m'a motivé
à faire les cent mille ça marche trop
sur moi aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il y avait de laëtitia
aujourd'hui à mater un nouveau jour on
était un jour de space parce que en fait
les cent mille abonnés de mon ami y
avait toutefois de voir alexandre colis
je connais pas ton prénom présence à lui
peut rien
j'ai mis d'accord passé une bonne soirée
il leur interdit à des locaux show oui
j'ai passé une très bonne soirée j'aime
à nous aussi urgent était formidable
merci beaucoup
ils ont essayé de me faire croire qu'ils
avaient pas le trophée à la fin moi j'ai
qu'on appelle bluffé j'ai été chanceuse
et josé pape ont fait galérer j'te
appris pendant qu'un milliard d'humains
sur terre et j'ai rajouté au marqueur 37
g drôle de film et c'est quoi ton prénom
quant à quentin celle du canton
merci d'être venus saluer clément bah
oui ce rapt le film est oui salut c'est
quoi ton prénom et oil india regardons
mais des pouces et des poussières médard
merci d'être venu linda s'affadissent m
benmosche a tellement pas dislike la
meuf elle vient moniteur elle fait sa
cible
d'accord ça représente quelque chose que
tu peux visualiser aussi un concept
c'est un conseil est d'accord tu peux
penser la première lettre de ce concept
c d e
il dit aussi copieux que tu prends ce
nombre de syllabes
ok ça peut être une deux trois d'accord
avec moi trois montants versés à 23 sa
rencontre face à ces matches devant
opposer une syllabe ou deux syllabes
c'est vrai certains ou 2 par 3 2 2 il
reste deux ou trois et ça fait 2 mois en
laye de l'es3 l'internet s'il est cette
lettre saison 4 est un concept on
apprécie très vite ça depuis un mois et
un sas de te remercie d une chaîne
youtube
abonnez vous à ma chaise
koné dangereux pour la santé a conseillé
avec précaution des amis vous pouvez
leur dire boit un coup mais fais gaffe a
conseillé avec précaution